okay you're good to go now councillor
thanks very much welcome everybody to
the uh
february the third meeting of the uh
council audit committee
the first item is attendances i think
we're just missing councillor evans and
councillor mitchell
uh so we'll put their apologies and they
might join us later on in the meeting
i don't think anybody else has got any
other apologies have we
i've just i've sent a text to councillor
evans and i'm just
sending an email to councillor mitchell
so see what happens
yeah thanks very much they can join us
yeah and nicki bishop sends our
apologies to you yeah
so i have i did have nikki support
forgotten about that yes yeah
item two's questions for members of
public
have we had any not received any check
thank you thank you
one part of the course item threes
minutes to the last meeting can we agree
those
as a true and credit record agree
we all in favor thanks very much
yeah item four is a strategic risk
update
that's actually been deferred into part
two the confidential section for
fairly obvious reasons it's a report
obviously on cyber security
item five is the external audit progress
report
i believe karen from mazzos is going to
do that
i am thank you chad it's a verbal update
um just to confirm for members that i
think
at the last meeting we said we had some
small amounts of outstanding work to
complete uh particularly in relation to
property plants and equipment valuations
uh and there were some other areas of
work hey standing but once all of that
was finished we would
sign the council's audit report um the
work on property implants and equipment
evaluations has taken us significantly
longer to complete than we thought
because we have had some challenges in
getting information from the valuer to
support the information that is included
in the council's accounts
we've been working really hard with them
but there have been a number of
uh factors that have contributed to that
delay
uh one of which is that we've got some
id problems at um the council's external
value
side which means they haven't been able
to provide uh information due to
difficulties in accessing their own
systems um
we are now as of today in a position
where we have
three relatively small outstanding
queries that the valuer needs to comment
back to us on at which point we will be
able to
conclude the audit there are some
unadjusted
errors that we will need to report back
to you through our audit completion
letter which we'll send out
um relating to the um
difficulties we've had i guess and the
areas in the underlying data that the
valuer
has been able to provide now but we will
just report those back to you i think
members if i take you back to this time
last year or a little bit earlier this
last year will recall that there were
some similar issues with the 18
19 valuation information and i'm afraid
they have
really um sort of repeated themselves
again
this year really and presented us with a
particular challenge
but just to reiterate i think we are
literally now days away from being able
to sign the audio report
thanks very much karen any questions for
members
i'm looking for no okay
thanks thanks very much okay thank you
thank you for that
item uh six is the uh
treasury management strategy and i
believe uh
frank fallon is going to do that is that
correct uh yeah that's perfect yeah
thank you hi hey
hey you know i'll just um run through
some of the
key aspects of the strategies that's
okay
um so primary purpose of the report is
to allow members to review
and ultimately for the council to
approve the treasury management strategy
for the next three years
and there's three key aspects of this
strategy there's the debt strategy
the investment strategy and then
prudential
limits in the report
economical with a medium financial
activity so he
so there's been a negative impact on the
world economy
and the current forecast is for the a
slow and gradual recovery
to begin later this calendar year
um what this means for the treasury
activity is that the current
interest rates first thing in this
few years
which for the outcome which was in
november and
frankly just interrupt there's a bit of
a bandwidth problem i think
if you turn your company off and just
speak that might help
sometimes yeah
so the outcome of the pwp consultation
is borrowing rates i
want defense addition to plan
for uh purely financial benefit
um so this has reduced the cost of
borrowing for the council but there are
no plans
for us to borrow additional amounts
outside of that required support
capital programme this means the total
debt
is estimate
[Music]
the end of this year rising to
71 million by the end of march 2020
um
[Music]
thank you breaking up um
okay uh
i just um i just try and get some of the
key bits out
then if i can um
so the key item in the investment bit
is that we'd like to increase the number
of approved building societies
from two to ten the reason for this
is that the current economic climate is
making
finding competitive places to
invest difficult so by increasing
the number of building societies on our
approved list
that should help with that process
um and then we have the
um i think there's al there's in the
[Music]
uh so those can be
we've lost you frank
okay can you hear me now i think i think
the
key change was the um
was the change in policy around the
building societies
most of these strategies the same
previous years
limit credential indicates increased
no we've lost you again graham can you
summarize
yeah yes uh is is that is it clear from
me
so so just finishing off from what frank
said
obviously the policy around the debt
strategy
obviously we only borrow for our capital
expenditure requirements
so to support the capital program or the
asset strategy
and within the report section 3.13
just details where we see our overall
borrowing levels for the council
um going to over the next few years but
it's purely in support
of our expenditure plans for the capital
program and the asset strategy
um i think
just to comment on the investment
strategy i think what frank was saying
is everything on the investment strategy
is um all focused around security of
cash
and i think what we're finding at the
moment is
the money market funds which we use to
invest our cash in the triple a rated
funds
we've not got a significant volume of
them and i think what we're mindful of
is we don't want to end up with all our
eggs in one basket so what we've looked
at to extend the number of
counterparties the people that we can
invest with is to look to extend
the strategy to cover our top rated
building societies
some of these don't have credit ratings
building societies don't
and that's not necessarily an issue
because what we look at on building
societies is the value of their balance
sheet
so it's it's what assets have they got
um and just the strength of their
balance sheet in terms of the net assets
they've got so we've taken the
the opportunity this time around to
increase and extend our investment
counterparty's list to include those
building societies
um the rest of the report obviously it
does comply with our
with the regulations which we need to
comply with on treasury
but it does detail and i think the
numbers
part of the report are included in
appendix 3
which sets out our
prudential indicators particularly
around
the amounts of borrowing and the
borrowing limits that we
impose on ourselves as a council so the
two main ones there that council approve
each year
is what we call the authorized limit for
external debt now that is the
maximum permissible ceiling so we have
to make sure we operate within that
there is something there called the
operational boundary which is more of a
day-to-day
limit that we try to operate within so
you've got the authorized limit which is
the real
top upper limit and the operational
boundary which is what we
attempt to operate within which is
slightly lower than the authorized limit
if we if we if we're achieving and
reaching the operational boundary we've
got
some slight concerns um if we ever
envisage we're going to exceed any of
these limits we must come back to your
yourselves and also to the council to
seek approval
um and explain why we may be breaching
any of those
um touchwood we've never done that when
we've set these indicators in previous
years and we don't foresee that now
um so i think in terms of the overall
report i'm just
i'm mindful that obviously we we had
some training that was presented by
graham perkins and the link group a
couple of weeks ago which hopefully you
found useful because obviously
our budget reports are quite long and
detailed
um but what they said we apologize for
that and i think that's just the nature
of where we are as a local authority and
that
we spend a lot of money uh and we invest
a lot of money and obviously we need to
make sure we comply with all the
relevant standards and guidance we've
got
so i think the main change to this
strategy this time
is is the issue around extending the
counter parties
as to who we can invest with um
the rest of the strategy is broadly a
roll forward from
from previous years so i'm happy to take
any questions if any of the
committee's got any thank you that's
that
thanks uh frank it's just technical
problems right there
yeah anyway any questions for graham
really
council winning stanley uh
thanks sure yeah just a question on
negative interest rates because that was
to me potentially quite worrying that
big organizations are now starting to
because negative interest rates been a
long time since my economics degree does
not mean we have to pay them to have our
money
it's again he asked he asked questions
that i was just asking last week when i
was reading it
i've never known negative interest rates
basically we are
for the privilege of people looking
after our money we would end up
giving them a hundred pound and getting
99 pound back
as an example it's interesting
when you think well what causes it and
it
if we think if we just take a step back
nationally this year obviously the
government
have been putting more money into the
money supply
to borrow back off the central banks to
basically give
local government local governments been
given a lot of money to bail out
businesses
so that's increased the money supply
businesses have got their money in
effect from us
businesses and the way i'm thinking the
businesses would ordinarily get money
from
customers customers at the moment
probably sat on balances so i think
overall what's what's creating this
fear of negative interest rates i think
is the volume of cash
that either banks have got businesses
have got in their bank accounts
and it's finding safe havens for that
money
so it's a lack of supply and demand on
money so they just don't want it they
don't want it
necessarily yeah and i i think
as as authority will we go into negative
interest rates i think
the answer will be
no and i think the way the money markets
work
and we we invest in what they call money
markets which are triple a backed
investment instruments
i think they've said that rather than go
negative they would just cut the amount
of fees they get from it so i think at
the moment
we are very low um
the investments returns we get probably
if i said up to half a percent would be
lucky
yeah um but we we still get that return
yeah um and we would hope we would still
get
a positive return not negative yeah it
comes down to security
yeah that explains why i've expanded the
number of
building societies from two to ten to be
able to increase that point
thank you thanks very much spread the
cash so we've gotta all go
i got our eggs in one basket yeah we
need to spread that got it
let's hope negative interest rates don't
spread throughout the rest of the
economy are you
yeah god yeah yeah yeah thanks for that
councillor coggins
thank you yeah um barry's covered some
of my
questions i mean graham's touched on
them as well to them three different
things about the negative interest rate
so as
um 5.13 it says several of the banks of
council users
have started to pay negative interest
rates whereas later on i think it's on
page 23
in the economic forecast it says the
monetary policy committee
has squashed any idea of using negative
interest rates
so i was i was wondering what's going on
there or are we looking at two different
economic levels where actually this is
what's happening on the ground in a
small scale
and there's something else happening uh
at the macro level
um or um if they're written at different
times and then i also wanted to ask
about
building societies so yes i i appreciate
the
comments graeme has given so it
mentioned here
and the thing that worried me was it
mentioned going to building societies
regardless of their credit ratings and
but from what graeme is saying now it
might
be much that they have a bad credit
rating rather than just they don't have
a credit rating
and that's because they're outside of
the credit rating system
rather than b because they're um risky
so i suppose just some clarification on
that
and and again if it's so moving from two
building societies to ten
um and obviously i see the reasons for
doing that and yet there was obviously a
reason we chose to only be at two so i'm
wondering
why were we not at ten before so what is
the alternative risk that we're taking
on
um and the final one the final one is a
separate issue is about 5.4 where we
talk about ethical investments
and how those i suppose the degree of
tension between
um the zipper guidance saying we have to
follow the slide principles on the one
hand
and the desire to follow ethical
investment principles on the other hand
so i'm wondering how much tension there
is really and how
differently we will be doing things if
we weren't constricted by the
principles which i realized there for
really good reasons and specifically i'm
thinking of the example being
pension funds where um the argument is
oh well they're really secure
investing in these fossil fuel companies
and and yet we know that fossil fuel
companies are not secure in the long
term because
there's a massive movement away from
them so three separate issues
thank you thanks graham
i'll just respond on the first one um
councillor coggins i think
i i will double check the references
about negative interest rates i know
um i responded to councillor win stanley
on on what i'd
understood last week um there was
articles from sip for on this last week
um i'm i'm not expecting negative
interest rates
at this stage to affect to affect the
council
um i think that's just something i'll
take back and we may have just look at
this
um report and just
just further put on on those issues and
the potential risks that that might get
us i think it's it's totally valid point
and i think it's a really topical point
because of what's come out recently
um the issue on building societies
um i think
if if we just roll back 10 years what
happened with building societies and
building societies were
on local authorities investment
counterparty lists so local authorities
did invest in them i think
in the financial crash i think
the value of their balance sheets came
under question
um particularly around their ability
to recover the amount of debt that
they'd got outstanding particularly when
property values had
reduced so i think their balance sheets
were weak and then at that stage
in effect they were dropped off local
authorities lists for that reason the
strength of the balance sheets was not
sufficient
uh to give us the security we wanted
when we're investing
i think the reason we have two i think
obviously i think nationwide was one of
them
i won't guess at the second one it's
obviously just the main big players at
that stage but i think we've taken the
view now that
there's more reliance and more
reliability on their balance sheets
and i think we've set limits there that
we would look at um
building societies with particularly
size balance sheets before we did any
investing in them
just in terms of ethical investments i
know it's something we have considered
as part of this strategy before we have
opened
i think money market funds i'll take it
back to our treasury manager
um as to as to what's happened with
those
potentially green investment vehicles
obviously in terms of the pension
authority this is not something we've
necessarily got a direct
control over their investing um
i think i would probably say that the
treasury function and the investments
around the treasury function
are really tightly governed um i know
with
the other aspect of the council's
investments that it does through the
asset investment strategy
this has just been obviously updated uh
in the last couple of months
to take into account and obviously
prioritize investments that had
um social and economic
benefits and would take that on board in
any investments we did
there that's not to say we we wouldn't
look to invest in ethical things through
the treasury
investment but as as we said the
governance is purely around sly the
security liquidity yield
priorities um so i think on that
geraldine i will certainly take back the
issue about the negative interest rates
and just get clarity in this report as
to
as to what some of the risks will be on
that and obviously i'll question the
treasury manager about the ethical
investment side as well
thanks that's really helpful i've i've
put the references in the chat for it
yeah
for the negativity sorry
boys next i think yeah very briefly
on the negative interest bit i mean it's
two reasons why they ever come about one
is
allegedly to try and uh get consumer
spending and investment uh
which by making borrowing cheaper
whatever to encourage people to take
money out of savings
and spend it which is particularly
difficult at the time the covid or
whatever because you can't
spend anything really unless it's online
so that is it's a
but the other thing is actually is it's
basically it's quite simply
to to cheapen the government borrowing
costs interest wise but i mean over time
it's it's been shown that this policy
doesn't really work you know
japan had it for quite a number of years
going back into the
like 2015 whatever other countries have
tried it
but by and large it doesn't really
achieve
either those objectives very very
very well and consequently it's unlikely
to happen
and it'll end up just hovering around
very very low rates as simple as that i
think yeah
okay thanks very much any other
questions
i can't see any anybody right so let's
just trim on my computer again hold on a
minute mr chairman sorry just going back
to one point just got on the previous
item so
i i just just realized and obviously it
was just a verbal report for our
external auditors
i assume that by the time we come to
march the 23rd in our next meeting
there'll be a sort of complete report
you know everything will have caught up
with what's
outstanding at the moment in their
digging and
delving into uh valuations and what have
you i'd just like to
make that clear that i think we expect
it to happen by then
yeah my intention is that as soon as we
are in a position to
um sign off which as i said earlier i'm
hoping we'll be in
the next few days early early part of
next week um
we will write to you uh with an audit
completion letter so that all members of
the committee
are clear in advance of the next meeting
about a number of things the first is
that the order is complete and the audit
opinion has been issued
and the second is the matters arising
from our work that were not reported to
your previous meeting
so we can then discuss that letter if
you if you wish to do so in the march
meeting but you will get the information
before then
thanks karen that's absolutely brilliant
thanks very much thank you thanks very
much
uh just just to mention we know what
we've
during the last debate where you're
joined by uh councillor evans and
councillor mitchell
uh item seven now we're on two is the
budget monitoring reporting
graham see you again it is yeah thanks
chair
um
i think just this this report is is the
report that went to the executive on the
25th
of jan last week so it just sets out our
projection
for revenue expenditure as at period
eight
so it took account of what we knew up to
the end of november
uh just some headlines from the reporter
we have included in it
um an executive summary just to try to
to bring out some of the more pertinent
points within this report but
what what we're forecasting at the
moment it's a bit of a
it's a more positive report than the
previous
um reports that we've presented this
year and i think what we've what we're
forecasting at the moment is an
underspend of 2.1 million
um i would caveat that
to say that at the time we drafted the
report
was prior to the latest national
lockdown
which will have an impact and will have
an adverse
impact but the extent that that adverse
impact is covered by some of the
government um
safety nets that there exist for example
if i use one example around
schools catering
where we recover income from schools
catering if
if the schools are closing we're not
doing that so it ends up as a loss of
income and a pressure on the budget but
in respect to sales fees and charges
governments have got a compensation
scheme for that so
so there are caveats to say we've still
got some
some pressures that we're still
quantifying
but like i say it's it's a relatively
good news position that we're
forecasting and underspend the 2.1
million now
the reasons for that and it's quite a
positive movement since the previous
report at period six i think is that
within the projections we were including
some allowances for
anticipated increases in children's
care costs and adults care costs as a
result of corvid
and what what we're thinking at the
moment is we're not seeing that demand
and that pressure coming through and
that's probably because we're still in
the
in the midst of of the corona virus
issues so
we've not seen that additional pressure
come forward
so at this stage we've been able to
release back some contingency budgets
that we've got
within the overall projections and
that's led to that underspent position
i think what it's worth saying though is
that
in respect to council tax and business
rates
and what we forecast will be available
to support budget when we set the budget
last february
we will see shortfalls in collection of
council tax and collection of business
rates
and across the two areas i put the
figures their council tax
is about 5.3 million business rates is
about three and a half million
what government said is we don't want
you to chalk that
up against your out-term position in
2021
we want you to in effect
spread that deficit over the next three
years
and that's not traffic that's for all
local governments so basically they've
taken the pressure away from us this
year
so had they not done that have they been
another eight million pound pressure
in year so we're not out of the woods
um what government said in terms of the
council tax business rates is you can
you can in effect
smooth that problem um over the next few
years what this position means
for reserves overall is quite positive
in that
any underspend we do get at year end
will be transferred to reserves to
bolster reserves and i think if you
remember at draft budget stage
there was reference to using reserves
to cover the budget in 2122 and to cover
some of those pressures that were
carrying on
from as a result of corvid
and i've just added a note there at the
bottom of the summary around the capital
programme
and it's quite a positive one in terms
of the amount of schemes that are either
committed or programmed to start this
year which is
worth about 97 of our budgeted plans at
the moment
which are about 40 million pound of
capital expenditure
so not wanting to get into too much of
that detail but
more than happy to take any questions
anybody might have on any aspect to the
report
thanks graeme councillor thompson i can
see indicated
thank you the the
loss of council tax and business rates
that we're allowed to carry over
into the next three years how will we
carry that over will it be
um evenly across the three years or
waited towards more towards the end or
so what it's an interesting question
because this is what we were asking
government
but it goes back to i think it was
around july time
that all through the year we've been
telling government
what the impact of it's been on our
expenditure
our income streams and funding and when
i say funded i mean council tax business
rates
so we've been telling them all the
issues now what they said in terms of
the funding is
um we acknowledge you've got pressures
and we will support you
so it it got to the stage where this
um the spending round came out from
government in october
and at that stage they what they said
was
if you're if you're gonna have a funding
deficit on council tax and business
rates we will support
about three quarters of that
so what what that basically means is we
look at the amount we're not going to
collect this year
government will give us a grant worth 75
percent of that
we write the deficit off over three
the following three financial years
equally so in effect we match it with a
grant so we've got a net deficit after
the grant and that's written off equally
over three years
so when we've done the when we've done
the budget plans for 2122 we've had to
accommodate
the issues that we've seen in the in the
current year
thank you okay okay
any further questions i can't see
anybody indicating so thanks for that uh
graham yeah okay
okay so we're onto item uh
eight which is the audit and assurance
report
period period eight i think is it all
closer to december
that's mark i think that's yeah
declare an interest yeah um just want to
declare an interest that i'm a governor
of stratford high school which is
mentioned in the report
okay thank you thanks um yeah so this
uh the committee at the last meeting got
an update for april to september
so this is a slightly shorter update
just covering the period october to
december
the work we've done um i think i
mentioned last time
the last meeting that uh see a lot of
changes to the audit plan with all the
changing circumstances
during the year um and you see in
section three of the report on page four
it
again makes reference to the other work
we've done around supporting the council
effort
um in terms of the administration of the
the kobe 19 grant
it's been a bit less activity from our
point of view in october to december but
we still probably provided some input
to that but mainly trying to progress a
number of our audits
um you see in section four
and then over the page on section five
um talks about the audit reports that
were produced during the period
um one one of the reports went out as a
final
uh which is very relevant on cyber
security that
uh paul james will be talking about the
end of the meeting
um a number of other reports issued to
draft stage
and currently we're in the process of
finalizing all those
so you'll get the details of the actual
findings of them at the next update
so the likes of reviews of payroll
insurance corporate complaints and a
school audit
and there's also a number of other
audits who are progressing i'd say at
this stage even though we haven't got
all the finals um of those reports are a
draft there are no
particular concerns in terms of opinion
levels that we'd expect them to be
sort of amber or red we'd expect them
all to be at least medium
and above opinion levels um in fact
uh some of them don't really expect to
be high
by the time they're issued as final um
in terms of work we've done as well as
the the audits
um section six on page 90
uh two uh lists other areas we've been
involved in as well as the
the grants um see other items that have
come to the committee strategic risk
register came in november
um we've also spent some time submitting
various information to the cabin
office uh supporting the national fraud
initiative
and there's some details of that in the
report in the appendix 3
um in terms of the data that's been
submitted
so there'll be work through the rest of
this year working with different
services for any
any data matches that come up for
potential
risks of errors fraud in transactions a
number of services particularly likes of
the fraud team and the accounts payable
teams will be
we're also working on that to explore
any errors and we'll report
we'll report on the details of that
later in the year
uh we've also linked him with our hr
section
in terms of their induction and there's
an updated e-learning on
fraud uh been added to the induction
arrangements um just
and and several of the areas they're
listed grants work disabled facilities
granted say as well
we were involved in certifying that
just just moving on to the impact of
audit work as we always report on
um no no significant concerns there all
recommendations today
have been accepted made in the report
with a lot of focus this period on
schools and follow-up work
um particularly conscious that we
haven't done as much
audits on schools as we as we would
normally expect to do hopefully that's
being rectified
over the coming months but we've done a
lot of work on
following up previous work and checking
for progress and implementing
recommendations
i think you've seen the report there's
fairly positive outcomes in terms of
all the schools they're listed in terms
of
recommendations either all being
implemented or most of them which is
which was pleasing to see
um and you see a chart there on page 93
summarizing which have been percentage
of recommendations implemented
the overall is 97 either been fully
implemented or
are in part in progress which again was
pleasing to see
um just moving to section 8 of the
report and update on performance against
the plan
and again i did mention this last time
um
overall number of days we've spent the
work time we've had has been pretty
equivalent to what we'd expected to have
but obviously the way we spent our time
has varied in some areas
um particularly uh schools as i
mentioned there's been less days spent
as we've rescheduled school audits um
and started to resume some
uh recently and obviously time that
we've spent around the grant's work uh
is reflected in the category there it
grant checks data quality
uh in the uh appendix one which sets out
the various time we spend there's a lot
more time spent on that area than we
expected to do
as i say in terms of the last time on
school audits we've tried to make up for
that a bit in terms of the fault work
and and planning in um audits over the
coming months
um what we're hoping really in terms of
what we produce for the year will be
less in terms of numbers of reports
but hopefully with the work that's been
done between now and the end of march
um there'll be a good good output of
reports across a variety of areas so we
can provide a a reasonable audit opinion
in our annual report
um probably in terms of numbers and
targets
it would be as i've said the schools
that will be the the figure that brings
us down
but we're addressing that by
rescheduling them certainly within 21-2
and building in a significant number of
audits
we've currently got two or two school
audits in progress that we're doing via
a remote
audit approach um
just turning in terms of the remainder
of the year
um you'll see in section nine
we just summarize uh areas of work
one of the key ones of putting together
the plan for next
year uh we're currently in progress for
doing that speaking to corporate
directors and heads of service
so the aim is to bring an audit plan
report to the next
committee meeting we'll also bring a
strategic risk update to the next
committee meeting we've
started work on that with with the
corporate directors
to provide that you see in appendix 2
there's a listing of audits audit
reports
and where they're up to um
you'll see there's a number that say
timing to be agreed on the right-hand
side in those cases
there's subjective discussions uh with
various corporate directors to agree
that and what's to be rescheduled
for the 21-2 um plan
so the next update i'll give will be the
annual report
which will come to the meeting after
next so that will include
the details for that you know for the
whole year in terms of audit work we're
doing and also
our not audit opinion um
so happy to to answer any any questions
on the report
thanks mark any questions
genie mrs splatt
hi everyone thanks chair mark could i
just
um ask just for a benefit of what's been
going on between
with the audit i mean in terms of having
enough
coverage for the external audit
um for reassurance in terms of the
schools
um is the external audit going to be
have you
obviously been liaising with them is it
going to take a different approach
because obviously taking into account
all the different circumstances you've
been facing
um when you say you mean with individual
schools dealing with the
just overall you know obviously
i mean we do have um regular contact
with with external audit
um i've had discussions today with with
karen
um so we do we do uh linking closely
uh on each other's work and um external
audit get a copy
of all our final audit reports as well
so that can help inform their work if
they've got any queries
and come back to us as well so there is
that there's like an ongoing yeah
i think okay yeah it was just in case
you know
obviously you can only do what you can
do in terms of the number of audits
so it was just whether you were then
obviously you're rescheduling them all
but whether there was anything else that
would come up because you've not been
able to
to do the coverage that you normally
would yeah
i mean we would look to prioritize uh
and obviously
any work whether it's mandatory and
there are deadlines and
we've certainly prioritized anything
like that for instance last week there
was a deadline to submit the national
ford initiative data
so we did that and and various other
things during the year
um and as far as the schools go um
we we have kept that going there's a
draft report in progress
there's another one just started um
things are a little slower
on that um but so we've tried to make up
for that as well with the follow-up work
and doing
bringing that forward a bit um so
hopefully
you know through the remainder of the
year as we've got used to a new approach
doing them um we should hopefully have
more of those
you know later in 2020 2021
okay thank you very much thank you lloyd
um adjust the um strategic risk
register um given that
we've um we had a report last time has
this lockdown
started to affect anything on this
strategic risk
um register and isn't it a living
document um because the thing that
concerns me
is we at the moment we don't know when
this is all going to end
and it has an impact on everything that
the council
does so it's almost like um
i don't know whether needs to come to us
a bit more regularly at the moment
rather um yes it
it is a living document you're right i
mean each of the risks has a risk owner
and each of the relevant services
directorates would
maintain that um i think for reporting
purposes
sometimes the timing of the committee
meetings can be a bit difficult to do
each meeting because for instance at the
moment the very close the february
uh and the march meetings so we're
actually in the middle of
updating the register at the moment so
we emails have come back and forth over
the last few days for updating of it so
march should sort of be the next logical
time
and then in the summer when the
committee next meets would they get
another another update then
but you write it as a living document in
the sense each of the individual risk
areas
you know would be updated as and when
thank you for that it's just as i can
foresee that
um at the moment um we've got
a good thing in the last document um
sorry the uh the document which
gives the finances and that
you have contingencies it's just that it
concerns me is how much contingencies
we need to plan ahead for and because
uh for example uh children and not not
all children are at school and
sometimes for example that's when things
happen
and also it's it what concerns me is the
volatile services so what they're the
ones that
are um dependent on need
um at all and certainly with within the
register there's the main code with 19
risk
sort of the headline risk but then all
the other ones most of them will have
have have an impact from code with 19
and there'll be updates around that
reflecting that
well i know i'm not then yeah okay thank
you very much
okay thanks anybody else any other
questions
i can't see anybody okay so on to item
nine which is the it's a
mark again but it's the council audit
work program
20 20 20 stroke 21.
mark very briefly chair on that um
says just the remaining meeting in march
to go so you see the agenda
listed there that includes an item from
the star procurement service so we'll
get a
presentation i think from lorraine cox
at the march meeting okay
any questions anybody can't see anybody
okay well thanks for that uh look
forward to the march meeting
so i think that uh brings us to
any other uh urgent business i'm not
aware of any uh gelding
non-reported chair now no so that's the
end of the uh
oh well we need to pass the exclusion
resolution for the press and the public
but that's the end of the uh the public
part of the meeting so
if we could agree to the item 11
exclusion of the press and public
because we need to consider this uh
security uh
matter can we all agree to that
yeah i'll take this agreement thank you
joe's going to close the meeting i think
yes thanks jeff if if you can just give
me a few seconds i'll i'll stop the
stream
and the recording hopefully i won't
close the meeting i'll come back to you
as soon as i've done that and let you
know when we're ready to go again if i'm
just giving